on my last video about marriage
I had a friend say that marriage is supposed to be your safe place
and I've never thought about it in those terms before
but she was exactly correct
there are so many awful things in this life that you were gonna go through
there are so many moments when you were gonna be self conscious
when you were gonna feel low
when you were gonna need propping up
and you undoubtedly are gonna go through some hard stuff
and marriage can be this beautiful gift that you give yourself
it is supposed to be the person that you can come to with all of your ails
your worries
your woes, your insecurities
and work through them and be supported and loved
and that's not to say that you can't get that in other relationships
but the added element of that lifelong commitment
that lifelong promise to each other to show up till death do you part
allows some of that reassurance that even if you are your worst self
sometimes they're gonna help you get through it
now I understand that that is not everybody's reality
and divorce exists in astronomical numbers for a very good reason
but there is that like
glimmer of hope and optimism when it comes to marriage
that doesn't exist in other relationships
I have Learned so much about myself
and so much about the good in the world through being married
marriage should feel like a warm blanket
like coming home
and if it doesn't
don't do it because it's still legally binding